board and if you play cc i have knight  c6 c2 look c4 as minimum yeah i mean and  probably maximum but it's good enough  yeah  just protecting the c pawn like this  and we are winning  oh my god yeah anish yeah okay but with  20 seconds on the clock to play such a  sharp position it's just impo and look  before yeah that's it  oh he just missed maybe rook before yeah  because we saw the bar also just shoot  up completely and anish shaking his head  completely missed this idea and that  means we've got a match on our hands  peter with the shark looking to equalize  the score  yeah absolutely  he's just gonna resign now  yeah he gonna design yeah look at this  yeah i mean making this sign with his  hand he's just disgusted yeah it's it's  just too much yesterday he blunted the  bishop with bishop e1 in the final game  now here he had a wonderful person i  mean it really felt like he had a  wonderful position and and it  ended in a total collapse